our YouTube this is impressive on you
while I managing director the World Bank
I'm talking today about investing in
girls and the girls affect the server
video a girl called and winter who
challenged all of us to think of how
specifically we can help to invest in
girls and make sure that girls get the
opportunity that she was denied earlier
on in her life I think we need to do
this at every level at individual level
each one of us feels privileged to be
better off and commits to try and find a
girl a group of girls in a developing
country where they are not so privileged
that they can help to make their lives
better you can do that from working with
an NGO there are many reputable NGOs who
are committed to helping ghosts and I'm
sure you can find who they are online
you should do that through institutions
such as mine the World Bank is very very
focused on girls we believe that
investing in girls is investing in
development if you invest in girls they
are at the bottom top and middle of
everything if i make it makes a
difference in climate change and
population in reducing poverty in all
the millennium development goals that
were so interested in so institutions
should commit on the World Bank is
committed we have a very good initiative
the focal focuses on adolescent girls in
proposed conflict and fragile states
because we believe that they deserve
tremendous attention if you look at most
of these days many of the girls are not
in school it's all thanks to them only
1% of the girls finish memories so we
are committed to change this and to make
an open the government's there make a
difference in these girls lives so the
question I have for you youtube
communities what are you going to do
after you listen to me talk after you
hear the story of an eater after you
think about the issue of girls after you
reflect on the fact that of the 130
million children authors for seventy
percent of what are you individually
going to commit to do
q I'd love to hear from you